[Music]
today we'll look at how robotic process
automation can increase employee
productivity and remove time and cost
from business processes we'll use an
account opening example to see how
robotic process automation or RPA
reduces manual processing time
eliminates copy and paste errors and
improves customer service the process
starts when a call center rep offers a
new line of credit account to an
existing customer the rep uses IBM
Business Process manager or BPM to
document the customer's request
including specific details about the
property being used for collateral all
other customer information will be
pulled from existing systems when a
sales assistant creates the account when
the call center rep submits the request
BPM automatically launches an automated
decision service in IBM operational
decision manager or odm that determines
the allowable amount of credit since the
credit decision completes in real time a
task is immediately generated for a
sales assistant to manually create the
new account
it takes a sales assistant about 20
minutes to open this new account but due
to a three business day backlog the
account can't be opened until next week
that will therefore be several days
before we send the customer documents to
sign
the following week a sales assistant
opens the task and sees the information
entered by the call center rep she also
sees the credit limit and a credit limit
confirmation ID that was assigned by odm
the sales assistance task is to now use
this information along with information
from two other applications to open a
new account in the line of credit
account system the assistant starts by
logging in to the customer information
master system she then copies the
customer number from BPM into the master
system in order to retrieve master
customer details
she then logs into the line of credit
account system in which she will open
the new account she returns to the
customer master system and one by one
copies and pastes all nine values into
the account opening system she then goes
to the BPM system and again one by one
copies 10 values into eleven fields in
the line of credit system since one of
the values must be pasted into two
separate fields she then logs into a
government website to obtain the
official tax value of the property being
used as collateral she copies the
property information from the BPM system
to the valuation website and retrieves
the tax valuation and assessment date
she copies these two values into the
line of credit account system and is
finally ready to click create account
this causes the system to open a new
account and generate an account number
which she pastes into BPM that completes
this human task and causes the BPM
system to move to the next step in the
process which is to prepare the
documents and send them to the customer
for approval the sales assistant is now
ready to move on to her next
asked after taking a quick break to grab
a cup of coffee that manual task which
took 20 minutes to perform required
logging into and navigating for
applications and copying and pasting 36
fields now let's replay the exact
sequence of events using robotic process
automation our PA is able to record all
the actions performed by the sales
assistant and then playback the actions
on command this includes logging into
applications navigating to specific
screens controlling applications using
the mouse or keyboard and copying and
pasting values between applications
let's watch as IBM our PA completes this
account opening tasks less than 45
seconds after the call center rep clicks
the submit button
[Music]
using our PA we were ready to send
documents to the customer 45 seconds
after the call center rep finished
speaking with them which is a much more
efficient and effective outcome than
having to wait three business days for a
sales assistant to spend 20 minutes
performing this repetitive and
error-prone task the benefits of using
our PA in this example are pretty clear
first we were able to respond to the
customer in 45 seconds versus five
calendar days second we eliminated the
copy and paste errors that often occur
in as many as 10% of manually copied
customer records and third we can free
up our people from this type of mundane
and repetitive work so they can focus on
the things that humans do best things
like providing personal empathy to
customers or using creativity to solve
problems or find new business
opportunities IBM robotic process
automation along with business process
management and operational decision
management can help increase employee
productivity and improve customer
service and who knows maybe now your
employees will visit the coffee machine
to boost their creativity instead of
just to stay awake give us a call or
come see us online so we can help you
take advantage of robotics in your
business automation
you